INSURANCE COMMITTEE HEARING OF.
SEPTEMBER EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON THE
AGENDA TODAY WHICH IS AB. ONE
FIVE ONE ONE. PLEASE BE MINDFUL
OF THE MAST REQUIREMENT FOR
EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC AND PARTICIPATE
IN TODAY'S HEARING BY CALLING.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE
PASSCODE. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN- OR YOU CAN
USE THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION ON THE NORTH STEPS OF
THE CAPITOL OR IN PERSON- LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DALY HERE DALY HERE MAYES
BERMAN BERMAN HERE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW HERE CALDERON CALDERON
HERE CHEN COOLEY COOLEY HERE
COOPER FRAZIER. FRAZIER HERE
GIPSON GRAYSON GRAYSON HERE
RODRIGUEZ VOEPEL YOU VOEPEL
HERE WOULD WOULD HEAR RECORD.
SO WERE. MISTER MAYNES WOULD
NORMALLY CHEER TO THEM TO
PRESENT THE BILL FROM THE-
TABLE OVER THERE KATIE SAYS I
HAVE TO SIT THERE. I DISAGREE
BUT I'M GONNA DO IT ANYWAY.
YEAH. DON'T TALK OUT OF IT
REVENUE. YEAH I'VE DONE BEFORE.
STRATEC CONSIDER CLOSING- THIS
SIMPLY ADDS A SENATE AMENDMENT
TO MORE ANNUAL INSURANCE ON THE
BILL ON THE MOST BILL
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR HI
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING THEM ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE PUBLIC. THIS IS YOUR
MEMBERS FOR SCHOOL SENIOR HAVE
THE REST OF THE FUTURE. RIGHT
AND I HAVE TAKEN. SORRY MR J.
MEMBERS CHRIS MCHALE ON BEHALF
OF ESOS OF CLAIMS PROFESSIONALS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. AND IF YOU DO HAVE IN THE
QUEUE A OF I'M HEARING- A
MICHAEL MARTINEZ SENIOR DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE- MODERATED YOU
HAVE MISTER MARTINEZ IN THE
QUEUE. I DO SIR YES. YES I'M
RIGHT HERE THANK YOU MISTER
FRAZIER. WE NEED- SCHIFFER'S
ARE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MICHAEL MARTINEZ HERE ON BEHALF
OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA AND CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT INSURANCE HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR EITHER THANK YOU.
WHEN WE GO THROUGH THE- SO DO
WE HAVE ANY- MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AND REMOTE TESTIMONY.
SEEING NONE THIS COOLEY DID YOU
HAVE A FOLLOW UP QUESTION. I
WAS WORKING TO MAKE A COMMENT
COIN IS A PROGRAM ROSE OUT OF
THE EARLY NINETEEN NINETIES AND
SOME OF THE- JUSTICE ISSUES IN
CALIFORNIA IN LA. IT PROVIDED
MORE FLEXIBILITY FOR HOME
INSURANCE TO INVESTMENTS TO
ALLOW THEM TO BE INVESTING IN A
BROADER ARRAY OF COMMITTEES
AROUND CALIORNIA. THE SENATE
MEMBERS ACTUALLY GOING TO THAT
LAW TO PROVIDE SOME UPDATED
FLEXIBLE IS ACTUALLY IT'S A
VERY. IS A VERY GREAT
AMENDMENTS TO SENATE BRING INTO
US AND AFFORD A SECTION HERE
THIS ONE IS RIGHT THANK YOU MR
CHAIRPERSON OF THIS BILL
PROVIDED A VEHICLE FOR THAT
CHANGE. THANK YOU MISTER DO YOU
HAVE STOLEN MY COMMENTS- AGAIN.
I ANY MEMBERS OF THE- IN THE
OPPOSITION TO THE OFFICE BILL.
ANY MEMBERS IN THE QUEUE
MODERATOR FOR OPPOSITION.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN
ELEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. BUT AGAIN IF YOU
ARE NOT POSITION YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. I SHOULD
NOTE COMING UP PROPOSITIONS.
HEARING NO OPPOSITION- OVER THE
TELEPHONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE REMOTE STATION IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. HEARING
SEEING NONE I WILL MOVE IT TO-
OF ALL OF THE- OF THE COMMITTEE
WE HAVE A FIRST I THINK MISTER
WOULD. A SECOND BY MYSELF
FRAZIER- THAT'S A GREAT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS
RECOMMENDATION BE CONCURRED AND
DALY DALY AYE MAYES. MAYES AYE
BERMAN BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CALDERON CALDERON
AYE CHAN CHAN I COOLEY COOLEY
AYE COOPER. FRAZIER BUT FRAZIER
AYE GIPSON GIPSON AYE GRAYSON
AS AND I RODRIGUEZ VOEPEL
VOEPEL I WOULD. WOULD I. IF YOU
WERE ACTUALLY LEGITIMATE THANKS.
AND A LOT OF WORK EITHER
THROUGH. OKAY RODRIGUEZ. YOU
HAVE TO SHE ALWAYS BEEN VERY
NUMBER ONE BILLBOARD THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR. YOUR WATER THE
GOVERNMENT RUN. COMMITTEE.
SOMETHING YEAH.
OKAY NOT RIGHT
NOW JUST WITH JUST ONE BILL.
MISTER RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I. THANKS BRO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
WHILE HAVING ON
THE FIELD LINE. EARNINGS YOUR.